[Music]
hey guys we are back in the absolute
lime green room I'm here with DT online
senior music editors sophie scholl AC
now absolute lime of course is the
newest refreshing flavor from Absolut
and we're breaking down all the
refreshing surprising moments for last
night's Grammy Awards and it's almost
one of those nights where you don't even
know where to start but of course we
start where the evening started on the
red carpet there you go that's the
natural place to start and everybody on
the red carpet was talking about Cee Lo
Green was it outrageous yes was a crazy
yes but it was actually part of this new
persona that Cee Lo is trying to make
happen called gnarly Davidson and he
wasn't the only bling on the carpet
Absolut lime also definitely made a
statement with their LED custom clutches
for their refresh to Talk campaign and
so I'm basically bringing the women's
March to the grab a red carpet and now
of course we got to talk about the
actual show amazing performances and
moments in there including when twenty
one pilots completely dropped trou when
they won Best Pop duo/group Performance
for their hit stress out and then of
course Courtin followed suit it's got an
amazing coincidence ready and now one of
the most meaningful performances of the
night Bruno Mars tribute to Prince Bruno
was in full purple rain mode but it
really left us wondering why haven't we
seen Bruno shredding like that on the
guitar before
incredible tribute right I mean and just
an overall incredible Grammys amazing
and that is gonna do it for us from our
absolute lime green room we hope you had
as much fun with the Grammys as we did
[Music]
you